let's find the Easter eggs in Sun one  notice anything on Sonic's bandana  that's the logo from the first sign to  the movie pays tribute to the wildly  popular sanic mean by using it as crazy  Carl's drawing of the blue devil that  nobody believes is real I almost caught  him last night  say hello to crazy Carl 3 the name of  the town of Montana or Sonic lives isn't  a random choice  Green Hills gets its name from Green  Hill Zone the first zone of the game for  in the game's dr. Robotnik is also known  as Eggman which sonic calls him in the  movie after mocking his drones that look  like flying eggs eggs are pretty  impressive mr. Eggman so uncool 5  longtime fans know that Chaos Emeralds  are important in the sonic games  observant viewers will notice a drawing  of an emerald on Sonic's map of safe  worlds see how many more Easter eggs you  can spot Sonic the Hedgehog now on  digital and on blu-ray May 19  [Music]  you